-10 -- count 'em --
10 Democratic candidates
squared off tonight
in the first debate
of the presidential campaign.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Donald Trump is
constitutionally incapable
of sharing the spotlight
with anyone,
and so as 10 Democrats
prepared to take the stage
for their first
primary debate tonight,
he went to something called
the Faith and Freedom Conference
to gurgle up a bunch of
old-man nonsense.
-We're saying
"merry Christmas" again.
Did you notice? Remember?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Remember?
I usually save that for
November, December,
but I was just thinking...
They were all taking it down off
the department stores,
everything.
You'd see a big red --
They'd say, "Happy holidays,"
no "merry Christmas."
They're saying
"merry Christmas" again.
It's very interesting.
"Our president may not be
the best at the Bible.
He may not have read it
2,000 times.
But he's the best for us."
My wife watched.
I said, "You have to see this.
It's great invention
It's called TiVo," okay?
I don't want to be advertising,
but, you know,
it's, like,
better than television,
'cause television, you
never see it.
With TiVo, you play it back.
I played it back.
-Oh, my God!
Get me off this cruise ship!
Is this a presidential speech
or bingo night?
This guy shouldn't be standing
behind a presidential seal.
He should be wandering down
the hallway of a group home
with a nurse chasing
after him, screaming,
"Donald, your gown is
on backwards."
I'm sorry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've just heard about TiVo?
Trump's brain is so
permanently stuck in 1999.
"Have you heard this new food
they just came out with?
It's called Go-Gurt.
It's a game changer."
Trump was probably more off
kilter than usual today
with the Democratic
debate looming
and the news that
Robert Mueller's agreed
to testify in public before
Congress next month,
and it clearly...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...clearly got in Trump's head,
because he called up
Fox Business News to
and ramble about Mueller
and accuse him of
a totally made-up crime.
Trump was referring to unearthed
text messages between
two FBI agents
who were having an affair,
or at least I think that's what
he was referring to.
-Robert Mueller --
they worked for him,
and the two lovers were together
and they had
texts back and forth.
-Well, how come
we haven't seen it all?
-You know why?
Because Mueller
terminated them illegally.
He terminated the e-mails.
He terminated all of the stuff
between Strzok and Page.
You know, they --
You've never --
Robert Mueller terminated
their text messages together.
He would -- He terminated them.
They're gone.
And that's illegal.
-Deleted!
The word you're looking for
is "deleted."
My God, man,
go back to watching TiVo.
And now you're accusing
Robert Mueller of a crime?
Look at this guy.
I doubt he's ever jaywalked
in his life.
Robert Mueller gives
speeding tickets
by chasing after cars on foot.
And no matter what you think of
the Democrats,
this is why it was refreshing to
see sane human beings
speaking in coherent sentences
about actual policies
on national television
for a change.
Now, this was just
the first of two debates,
with 10 more candidates
scheduled to debate on Thursday.
In fact, there are now
a total of
24 Democrats
running for president.
Look at how many people
are on that screen.
There are so many people,
you didn't even notice
that one of them is Guy Fieri.
And...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And he's definitely more
qualified than Donald Trump,
because, need I remind you,
he's the mayor of Flavortown.
Great bowling alleys,
terrible schools.
Of course...
[ Laughter ]
We'll just --
We'll cut out that.
Cut out the Flavortown joke
I fought for all day.
Live?!
Of course, with 10 people
on the stage,
the candidates knew it
would be tough to stand out,
which is why they were all
preparing in different ways
to make their case as concise
and effective as possible.
-Senator Elizabeth Warren
and her 2020 Democratic rivals
are very busy right now,
because they're prepping for
the first pair of
Democratic debates.
Warren has focussed on boiling
down her positions,
her policy positions, to try to
fit the time constraints.
Senator Amy Klobuchar has spent
time watching the 2016 debates
to see how President Trump
and his GOP rivals
stood out in that crowded field.
-Wait. You're studying Trump's
debate performances
to see how he stood out?
Which ones did you watch?
Did you study the tape of that
time Trump and Ben Carson
missed their cues
and got stuck in the hallway
leading to the debate stage?
'Cause that is a case
where he stood out literally.
And it really is amazing that
out of everyone on the stage,
the two guys who ended up
in the federal government
are the ones who turned
a presidential debate
into an escape room.
"Help us, clue master.
We need a hint."
Seriously, what lessons
can you learn
from Trump's
debate performances?
"Okay, just remember,
yell as loud as you can,
limit your vocabulary
to four words,
and, if you get lost,
just remember to act natural
and stare directly into
the camera.
like you're having
your portrait drawn."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, before the debate,
the candidates also showed up
to check out the debate stage,
like Ohio Congressman Tim Ryan,
who got caught sporting
a very casual look.
-2020 contender Tim Ryan is on
the debate stage right now,
doing his walk-through.
That's going to be happening
through the course of the day.
We do have a presidential
candidate right with us.
There's Tim Ryan
wearing his cap backward.
-"Uh...
Hey, guys, there aren't cameras
here now, right?"
Did you get confused and think
this was your
office softball game?
You don't look like a candidate.
You look like you should be
pounding some
Sam Adams tall-boys
at a Red Sox game.
Now, say what you will
about the Democrats.
Most of them seemed to enjoy
talking about policies,
and the campaign so far has been
incredibly substantive.
Senator Kamala Harris has a plan
for cash payments to
middle-class household.
Senator Bernie Sanders
rolled out a plan
to cancel all student debt.
And Senator Elizabeth Warren
was so excited
to discuss her plans to tax
the wealthy at a town hall
that she could
hardly contain herself.
-Thank you, Senator Warren,
for being here.
How the do you plan to make sure
the extremely rich pay
their fair taxes?
-Whoa!
Taxes!
That question was
Elizabeth Warren's Mardi Gras.
Asking Warren that question
is like walking up
to Chris Cuomo
at a party and going,
"Hey, you know anything
about CrossFit?"
And that excitement
for talking about policy
seems to have caught on, because
while the polls
have stayed mostly flat so far,
Warren's stock has been rising,
and that's caught
the attention of both
the Democratic front-runner,
Joe Biden, and President Trump.
-New polling shows Warren's
economic message
is resonating with voters.
In the latest NBC News/"Wall
Street Journal" poll,
26% of Democratic primary voters
say they're enthusiastic
about her candidacy.
That's a 6-point bump
from last month.
It might explain why Biden's
team is also reportedly
getting a little worried
about her rise.
And President Trump's campaign
is zeroing in on
the threat that she could pose.
-Oh, come on.
Donald Trump doesn't zero in.
If anything, he zeros out.
And I especially can't imagine
him zeroing in
on Elizabeth Warren.
For one thing, Warren literally
did an interview
where she was running to catch
a train at Penn Station.
Can you imagine if Trump was
late for a train?
Forget answering questions.
Mike Pence would have to carry
him on his back
like a tired 4-year-old.
So, with Warren
the obvious standout
coming into this debate,
the other candidates
were looking for ways to shine,
and former Texas Congressman
Beto O'Rourke
settled on a strategy of going
bilingual right out of the gate.
-This economy
has got to work for everyone,
and, right now,
we know that it isn't.
And it's going to take
all of us coming together
to make sure that it does.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
-I mean, I knew he was going to
bust out his Spanish.
I just didn't know
it would be that quickly.
Remember, Beto, you only
have one bullet,
so don't fire until you see the
whites of their -- Bang!
Also, check out
Cory Booker's face
when it cuts to him during
Beto's answer.
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
-Now, you might think that's
a face of a guy thinking,
"I can't believe you're
pandering by speaking Spanish,"
but it's actually the face of
a guy thinking,
"Oh, man!
I was gonna do that."
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
-Not only do I applaud them
speaking Spanish,
you just know everyone in
tomorrow's debate
who doesn't speak Spanish
is going to spend
the whole day cramming.
"I think all Americans
want answered --
the question they
want answered is,
'¿Donde esta mi gato?'"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Beto has been
struggling in the polls,
despite the national fame
he gained
from his Senate campaign
against Ted Cruz,
but he was still head
and shoulder above some rivals
in name and face recognition,
like, um...this guy.
-Congressman Delaney,
do you agree?
-I think we need do real things
to help American workers
and the American people.
-Okay, quick question --
who are you?
You look like you were
supposed to be in
a lawn-care commercial
during the break,
but they just accidentally
let you stay.
And then there was Tim Ryan,
the Ohio congressman,
who seemed maybe
slightly surprised
that he got a question.
-Congressman Ryan,
President Trump --
and you just referred to him --
promised that
manufacturing jobs
were all coming back to places
like your home state of Ohio.
Can you make that same promise?
-Yes, I believe you can.
-Tim Ryan always looks like
his dog just talked.
"Rusty, did you just say,
'Good morning'?"
Then the debate moderators
gave the candidates
a chance to
differentiate themselves
with a key policy question --
who would abolish
private health insurance?
And only a few
raised their hands.
-Who here would abolish their
private health insurance
in favor of
a government-run plan?
Just a show of hands
to start off with.
-Not only did Warren
raise her hand,
but check out New York City
mayor Bill de Blasio.
He's got to be so happy
he raised his hand
when Warren did.
It's like when
you're taking the SATs
and you peek at
the valedictorian's test
and make sure she had
the same answer.
And de Blasio clearly said
it's an opportunity
to make a name for himself
on the healthcare issue,
because after Beto
answered the question,
de Blasio jumped in
and went after him.
-Would you replace
private insurance?
-No. I think the choice is
fundamental to --
-Wait, wait.
Congressman O'Rourke,
private insurance is not working
for ten of
millions of Americans.
When you talk about the co-pays,
the deductibles,
the premiums,
the out-of-pocket expenses,
it's not working.
-That's right, so for those for
whom it is not working,
they can choose Medicare.
-Congressman, you've got to
start by acknowledging
the system is
not working for people.
-Look at those two.
They look like stockbrokers who
got too drunk at happy hour.
It's so weird to watch
two guys get into it
who are both polling
in single digits.
It's like watching the
New York Jets play guys
who got cut from
the New York Jets.
De Blasio was so eager to get
a word in that, at one point,
as they were cutting to
commercial,
he started yelling over
the moderators.
-Put the American people first.
-Hey, but wait a minute.
-All right, we are out of time.
We're up against a hard break --
-Neither Democrats, nor
Republicans have been serious --
-Mayor de Blasio,
we'll have more.
The commercial is coming.
-Oh, man, that's so New York.
It's like when you're trying
to talk to someone
as the subway doors are closing.
"Hey, what did you call me?!
What did you say, pal?!"
Of course,
I'm referring to a time
when the subway doors
in this city closed.
So, it was a very substantive
issue-oriented debate.
And after about an hour full of
complex policy questions
about everything
from immigration
to gun control to healthcare,
the president decided
to weigh in with his own
contribution to the debate,
tweeting, "Boring."
Oh, I'm sorry.
Are you not entertained,
Caligula?
I'd say we should send you out
there to spice things up,
but you'd probably just get
stuck in the hallway.
"This escape room is boring."
Also, don't you realize that
most Americans
are dying for things
to be boring for a while?
I fantasize about the day
I turn on CNN
and there's a banner that says,
"No breaking news."
Things were also a little weird
when the debate
switched over to the second hour
for moderators Rachel Maddow
and Chuck Todd,
who decided to start out with
some friendly banter.
-Now, the candidates will have
60 seconds to answer,
30 seconds for a follow-up,
if necessary.
And we will be ruthless,
-Yeah, we can do that.
-Mm-hmm.
-By the way, hi, Rachel.
-Hi, Chuck.
-How you doing?
-Good.
-Hey, guys,
we don't need the hellos.
We know you know each other.
The candidates each get like
9 seconds to speak,
and you're chatting it up
like old college friends
who ran into each other
at Fuddruckers.
It's like they
were waiting for somebody
to come by and take their order.
But then once they got
the hellos out of the way,
they were ready to go
with a smooth transition
in the next portion
of the debate.
-Many people are calling for
a restoration
of an assault-weapons ban,
but even if implemented,
there will still be
hundreds of millions of guns
in this country.
Should there be a role for the
federal government --
-I think the other mics are on.
-Oh, everybody's mics are on.
I think we have a --
I heard that, too.
That's okay.
I think we had a little
mic issue in the back.
-Control room, we've got --
-I think we heard -- Yeah,
we have the audience audio.
-What's happening?
-We are hearing
our colleagues's audio.
If the control room
can turn off the mics.
-There's voices behind us.
-Yeah, if the control room
can turn off
the mics of our previous
moderators, we will --
-I think it's the
prior moderators.
-You know,
we've prepared for everything.
We did not prepare for this.
-We are going to take
a quick break.
We're gonna get
this technical situation fixed.
We will be right back.
-Maybe you guys should have
spent more time
checking the audio and less time
saying hello to each other.
I'm surprised Warren
didn't bust out a tool kit.
"I can fix it."
And, of course, our
TV-game-show-host president,
who has nothing to say about
policy, had plenty to say
about the technical glitch,
tweeting, "NBC News and MSNBC
should be ashamed of themselves
for having
such a horrible
technical breakdown
in the middle of the debate.
Truly unprofessional
and only worthy
of a fake-news organization
which they are."
Boring!
Hey, man, I wouldn't be tweeting
about technical glitches.
You think TiVo is
new technology.
"NBC needs better
audio equipment.
They should have used a Zune."
Although, you know
he was TiVo'ing
that moment multiple times.
"Melania, get in here and watch
sleepy Chuck Todd
get interrupted."
Bloop-bloop.
But a big question underlying
all these policy debates
is this -- how will you get
your agenda passed
if there's a
Republican Congress?
The moderators asked Warren
if she had any ideas
for dealing with that,
and her answer was unequivocal.
-Do you have a plan to deal with
with Mitch McConnell?
-I do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Damn!
If Mitch McConnell were capable
of feeling human emotion,
he'd be terrified right now.
That's the moment everyone
else wondered,
"Maybe I should just go."
That was like when the matriarch
of a Southern dynasty
stands up at
the dinner table and says,
"I've made a decision."
When Warren said that,
Booker's face
got permanently stuck like that,
and Tim Ryan's hat
got flew back onto his head.
Everyone was eager to
get a word in,
like Washington governor
Jay Inslee,
who's running a campaign focused
primarily on climate change.
He tried to get some attention
from the moderators
and then made it kind of weird.
-Thank you, Senator Booker.
Rachel's got the next question.
-We are going to make --
We are going -- Hold on.
Governor, you're gonna be happy
with where we go.
Governor Inslee,
this next question is to you.
You got me?
-Rachel --
-You got me?
-Oh, my God.
What does that mean?
"I'm keeping an eye on her"?
He's like the corny dad
at the party
who wants to make sure
everyone's had enough to drink.
"Chad, I'm onto you, buddy.
When that marg's empty,
I'm getting you a refill, Chad."
Ultimately, tonight's debate
showed us that
a substantive campaign focused
on issues people care about,
rather than incoherent rambling
about Christmas
or terminating e-mails
is possible,
but it also proved once again
that there's
a reason "Jeopardy!"
has three contestants
and not 10.
"Alex, Alex, call on me!
I have a Final Jeopardy!
answer."
And if you missed
tonight's debate,
don't worry -- the president has
a high-tech solution
for how you can watch it.
-"It's great invention
It's called TiVo."
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪